مساء الخير على الارجح ما فيش حد من
حضراتكم لم يسمع عن قضيه كشمير كشمير
البلد الذي وصفها الرئيس الامريكي بل
كلينتون سنه الفين واثنين عن حق بانها
اخطر مكان على وجه الكره الارضيه
لا انا اتكلم عن كاشمير النهار ده ولا
الرئيس الامريكي وصفها في هذا الوصف دا
موضوع حلقتنا انا بتكلم عن كبير تجدد
التوتر
وخطر اندلاع حرب مجددا بين الدولتين
اللتين الهند وباكستان على خلفيه
صراعهم التاريخي على كثير وده بعد ما م ما
يسمى بجيش محمد بعمليه انتحاريه على ارض
كثير ادت الى مقتل سته واربعين جندي كندي
والهند وتتوعد باكستان بردو
القصه ايه وبدات الزاي كاشمير منطقه تقلق
العالم و تؤثر علينا زي ما تاثر على باقي
دول العالم
عشان نفهمه لازم نرجع سبعين سنه الوراء
وتحديدا في سنه الف وتسعمائه وسبعه
واربعين
استشهد تحدث مهم جدا
الحرب تمثل في خروج بريطانيا مرغمه من شبه
القاره الهنديه
الامبراطوريه البريطانيه بعض الدول سنه او
طويله جدا من احتلالها بريطانيا خرجت
مرغمه بعد ان خارت قواها في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ويبدو لاسباب يطول شرحها
ان من مصلحتها ان يتم تقسيم شبه القاره
الهنديه على اساس ديني الى دولتين دوله
ذات اغلبيه هندوسيه وهي الهند ودوله ذات
اغلبيه مسلمه وهي باكستان لكن الدوله يمكن
فيه مجموعه كبيره جدا من الامارات كانت
وقتها بدو يسمى بين هي عباره عن دول او
امارات صغيره جدا يحكمها امراء اسم احراجا
في الغالب وهؤلاء المعراج كانوا يحكموا
هذه الامارات الى صالح الامبراطوريه
البريطانيه
نظريا كانت لهذه الامارات الحريه في ان
تنضم الى الهند وباكستان او ان تظل على
دوله مستقله لكن عمليا الاغلبيه العدديه
من حيث الدين هي اللي حسب قرار كل امير
وبقت كاشمير كانت مشكله كشمير اللي كان
المحرجه اوامرها اسمها انه هندوسي
والاغلبيه من المنطقه التي يحكمها مسلمه
فتخيل انه ممكن ان يظل في هذا القوى
العاصف ال اودى بحياه عشرات الالوف في
مذابح اثناء عمليات الانفصال انه ممكن ان
يبقى على الحياد لكن لم تمهله الاحداث
ولانه كانت باكستان تضع انها على كثير من
اللحظات الاولى لميلاد باكستاني كبيره
وبالفعل التقسيم حصل فيه اغسطس الفين اه
اه سنه سبعه واربعين في اكتوبر كانت في
قوات غير نظاميه من باكستان تدخل الى
كشمير املا ان هي تفرض الامر الواقع
المهراجا شعر بالخطر على حياته يطلب
النجده من الهند وهناك وقع في اكتوبر قرار
او اتفاقيه دم
كشمير الى الاتحاد الهندي دوله الهند
الهنديه فرصه جيده جدا ان هي او حقه جيده
انها تدخل وتفرض نفوذها او تستحوذ على
كثير واندلعت الحرب الاولى ما بين البلدين
الحرب الاولى ولم تكن الاخيره لان البلدين
دارت بينهم اربع حروب ثلاثه منهم على كثير
سبعه واربعين خمسه وستين سنه تسعه وتسعين
بالاضافه الى حرب اخرى كانت سنه واحد
وسبعين
ال ال ال ال الحرب الاولى اللي انتهت بوقف
اطلاق النار بتدخل الامم المتحده انتهت
على ايه العمليات العسكريه الى تقسيم
كاشمير الى نصفين نصف كبير شويه حوالي
خمسه وستين في المائه
وتسيطر على القوات الهنديه وحوالي خمسه
وثلاثين في المائه تسيطر عليه القوات
الباكستانيه
وكان المفروض ال وقف اطلاق النار ده والخط
الفاصل اللي يكون مؤقت الى حين انه تنسحب
قوات البلدين
ويعقد اه استفتاء يحدد فيه شعب كثير ما
يريده بحريه لكن لم يحدث انسحاب ولم يتم
هذا الاستفتاء ابدا الى يوم الاحد الصراع
في منطقه كاشمير اللي مضى عليه اكثر من
سبعين سنه شك الكثير من احداث القرن
العشرين واتمنى او قد يشكل كثير من احداث
القرن الواحد وعشرين
يعني مثلا كانت اول توابع الصراع في كثير
سباق تسلح نووي ادى الى انه الهند تصبح
دوله نوويه
وباكستان دوله نوويه ازاي
الحرب البارده شكلت كثير من اشكال الصراع
او من تطورات الاحداث في كشمير
سنه اثنين وستين على سبيل المثال
دخلت الصين على خط المواجهه في منطقه كثير
ايضا وكان عندها خلاف حدودي مع الهند
وعندها خلاف ايديولوجي مع او خلاف يعني في
السياسات مع الاتحاد السوفياتي تعرفين في
الفتره دي اثناء الحرب البارده انقسم
العالم لمعسكر شرقي كانت الاتحاد
السوفياتي معسكر الغرب
الهند اللي كانت تدعم ما يسمى ب دول عدم
الانحياز كانت قريبه فعليا الى الاتحاد
السوفياتي
وباكستان بطبيعه الحال كان فيه المعسكر
الغربي مع الامريكان الصين اللي هي
المفروض ان هي في المعسكر الشرقي كان
عندها خلافات مع الاتحاد السوفياتي
وخلافات حدوديه مع الهند فقررت ان هي تحسم
ها في سنه اثنين وستين ودخلت الى منطقه
كاشمير وخرج بعد حوالي شهر شهرين يعني بعد
حرب قصيره نسبيا لكن خرجت بعد ان انتزعت
حوالي ثمانيه واربعين كيلومتر مربع من
منطقه كثير
الهزيمه دي حلت الهند تصر على انها تصبح
دوله نوويه حتى تكون قادره على مواكب هذا
انكار العملاق اللي هو السجن في المستقبل
بعد اربعه حروق خسرتها باكستان منها ثلاثه
على كشمير كانت مصره على ان تطور باكستان
ترسانتها وتصبح دوله نوويه حتى تكون قادره
على مواجهه كرتها النوويه الهند واصبحنا
والدا مسبق تسلم الحقيقه انه المساله لم
تتوقف عند هذا الحد
لانه الواقع العمري من الدولتين اصبحوا
نوويتين لكن بعيدا عن السلاح النووي اللي
هو الخيار الاخير او الملاذ الاخير
الحقائق كانت وما زالت بيقول ان الهند
متفوقه على باكستان على كل الصعد علميا
وديمقراطيه يعني وتكنولوجيا على كل الصوت
ومن بين هذه الصعب ان هي على مستوى
الاسلحه التقليديه يعني الطيران والدبابات
والمدفعيه اكثر تفوقا من باكستان
باكستان حبه تعاون هذا التفوق في الاسلحه
التقليديه
بان هي توظف ما هي ايده فيه وهي الجماعات
الجهاديه
والسبب قبلها او اقبلها على هذا ال ال ال
التكتيك او الاستراتيجي مشتركه كمان
مفهوما اولا هي دوله قامت على اساس ديني
يعني ما فيش اي مقومات لباكستان كدوله
يعني بمعنى انه مثلا بلد زي مثلا ايران هي
بلد موجوده سواء المسلمين او غير المسلمين
العرب او ايرانيين في هذا المكان من الاف
السنين لما باكستان تجمع المسلمين من
اماكن مختلفه من شبه القاره الهنديه فقط
لانه مسلمون ف بطبيعه الحال انه ممكن يكون
التفكير في توظيف الهويه الدينيه مفهوم
الامر الثاني ان الغالبيه العظمى من
كبيركم مسلمون ايضا وبينهم وبين الحدود
بعضهم اعداء وبالتالي بدا توظيف الجماعات
الجهاديه سواء من كثيرا وما من غير كثير
من غير الكشميريين
وباكستان عمله بتشجيع من الولايات المتحده
وقبلها بتشجيع من بريطانيا لانهم جميعا
موظفوا الجماعات الجهاديه كما يعلم حضرتكم
يعني بالتاكيد في افغانستان الملاصقه
لباكستان
لاستنزاف الاتحاد السوفياتي وارادوا تكرار
التجربه في استنزاف اي استهداف الهند عن
طريق الجماعات الدينيه
الفكره ديه اللي بدات وتعددت في جماعات
كثيره جدا برعايه معلنه احيانا من اجهزه
الامن الباكستانيه وفي معظم الاحيان غير
معلنه فبعدين عشرات الجماعات منها الان
على سبيل المثال ليش محمد اللي عمل
العمليه الاخيره عسكر طيبه اولا شكر قيمه
زي ما بيقولوا عليه احيانا حزب المجاهدين
حركه الانصار مجاهده يقدر وغيرهم الجماعات
دي زي كل الجماعات حتى لو كان بعض اعضاءها
معتدلين وعندهم اهداف مجرد تحرير يعني
التحرير الوطني حكم ب ايديولوجيتها
وتفكيرها التمدد وتتعاظم تتعاون مع جماعات
اخرى طالبان في افغانستان
جماعات دينيه في اماكن كثيره من اسيا بدءا
من بنغلاديش اسرى لينكون بالوبر ما اماكن
كثيره وطبعا افغانستان وطبعا منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وطبعا كوسوفو كل الاماكن اللي
بيكون فيها صراع يعني اعتقد الجهاديون انه
هما يذهبوا فيه الى نصره الدين الاسلامي
او لحضرتكم على مثال يعني قلت تعرف بولايه
من كم سنه البريطانيين كان عندهم يعني
استفسار كثير من العمليات اللي تمت ضدهم
او في اوروبا بيدوروا يجدوا انه صاحبها اه
يعيش في المنطقه
لدرجه ان البعض اطلق على بيرمنغهام ده
قلعه التطرف في بريطانيا بالبحث اكتشفوا
اللي فكثير من الاهالي كثير نزحوا هربا من
الحروب الى المملكه المتحده بس تقرا في
منطقه برمل في التسعينات بدا بعد الزعماء
السياسيين والدينيين في منطقه كاشمير
ياتوا الى بريطانيا بحثا عن التمويل من
البريطانيين من الاصل الكشميري وهم
بيقدموا التمويل كمان يحفز وهم وبينهم
واحمسهم للجهات في سبيل الله النتيجه ان
يبقى في اعاده كبير جدا من الجهاديين اللي
موجودين في بريطانيا على خلفيه كاشمير
على كشمير يعني يعني لم يعد سرا ان هي
اثرت على ملفات كثيره وكثير من الكبير
اللي بومدين سواء في ال اه يعني انضموا
الى دمشق مؤخرا اللي موجودين في شبه جزيره
سيناء ها اللي موجود في اماكن كثيره من
العالم جزء منهم اما من اهالي كاشمير او
من الجهاديين اللي خدموا في منطقه كاشمير
تماما زي الجهاديين اللي خدموا في اماكن
كثيره من العالم ومنها افغانستان فتح ولا
تشير الى قدره لتصدير المتطرفين الى كل
العالم تاثرنا جميعا بهم رغم اللي كثير من
الدول العربيه شاركت في دعمهم في بعض
الفترات
الحقيقه ان الخلاف على كثير او الصراع ما
بين البلدين
على كشمير ما كنش بس خلف حدودي هو بدا
الكلام
انما تطور وكان
قدر هذين البلدين يعني مرتبط دائما بكثير
يعني مثلا مشكله المياه الان وتتصاعد وهي
اخطر من الخلاف الحدودي على كشمير
وبردو مركز الصراع هو كشف اللي يشوف
الخريطه كويس خريطه كشمير ها يلاقي انه
النهر نهر السند العظيم اللي بيطلع من
منطقه التيبت في جبال الحملات بيجي من
امتد يعد الاول على المنطقه اللي من تسيطر
عليها الهند ثم الانديه في اعلى النهر
وبعدين منها بيعبر الى باكستان وهو
النهار السنه وروافده الخمس يعني مؤثرين
جدا جدا في حياه باكستان وب يعتمده لانه
بيجي بيشكل عندهم خوف كبير وكثير من حياه
الباكستانيين بتقوم على اه نهر السند
الهندي فكرت مبكرا تستخدم الميه وتقطع
المياه عقب باكستان منذ الحرب منهم سنه
ثمانيه واربعين سهله بالنسبه لها تدفق
المياه كله طبعا فتنبهت باكستان وطالبت
انه لازم يكون في اشراف دولي و اتفاقيه
دوليه
قاعد تغطيه نار السنه سنه ستين لكن رغم ان
الاتفاقيه الموجوده لنزاع مستمر
طبعا تفاصيل كثيره جدا لا يتسع الوقت
اليها لكن خلاصتها ان الهند مع الحاجه
الكثيره للميه بدات تقيم السدود نظريا هي
ملتزمه في القانون الدولي لكن مع تعدد
السدود الكلام ده بياثر على تدفق المياه
والباكستانيين بيقولوا اما ان يتدفق المال
او يتدفق الدم
يعني نوع من ال من تدفق الدم رئيس الوزراء
الحالي موده رئيس وزراء الهند
العماره مشابهه اللهم اما ان يتدفق الماء
او ان يتدفق الدم يعني اذا كان يتوفق الدم
بنتها تسيل دماء عن طريق القياديين لن
يتدفق الماء اليكم قصه الماء الصحه كما
وهي ايضا موجوده على منطقه كاشمير اللي هي
بت غزه شريان الماء الاساسي
باكستان
الطريق انه اساسا من بعض السنه جايه من
منطقه التيبت ومنطقه التهابات منطقه يعني
تقع تحت السياده الصينيه حتى الان
السلم تتدخل في النزاع المالي لكنها قد
تدخل وما فيشي اتفاق بينها وبين الهند على
حسب تعقد علاقتها بالهند تتاثر ايضا
علاقتها باكستان وفي كل الاحوال بتتكلم
على مركز صراع موجود في كاشمير
نتيجه الصراع اللي موجود ما بين الهند
وباكستان
انتقل الصراع الى ساحات مختلفه اشهر هذه
الساحات الحربي بالوكاله ما بين الهند
وباكستان في منطقه افغانستان واحد اشكال
الصراع ايضا ان كباكستان عن طريق المياه
في نهر كان بيجي من افغانستان يصل الى
باكستان وعناصر المهم الهند تمول
افغانستان لبناء سدود على كابول ما يؤثر
على حياه
الباكستانيين وفي المقابل الباكستان تدعم
حركه طالبان وعشرات من الجامعات الموجوده
اللي موجوده في افغانستان اللي بتهدد
الهند تقوم بعمليات مش بس على خط الفاصل
في كاشمير ولكن داخل الهند
وعمليات كثيره شهيره منها مثلا عمليه
الشهيره اللي راح ضحيتها سنه الفين
وثمانيه مئات من الجهود
اللي عاوزه اقول لحضراتكم لانه قصه طويله
انه الصراع على كشمير السلام ممتد
وساخن جدا ما بين الدولتين وفي اطراف
كثيره دخلت الى الصين اللي هي اه طبعا لها
علاقات فيها على تطور وان كان فيه تعاون
بيت مع الهند لكن في علاقه اقوى مع
باكستان وبالتالي هي باكستان الى حد كبير
في صراحه مع الهند الروس الامريكان الدول
العربيه كلها اطراف بتاخذ مواقف مختلفه من
هذا الصراع اللي هي هدد العالم كله انه في
حاله اندلاع وسخونه قد ياتي على الاخضر
واليابس ليس في الهند وباكستان
ولكن في العالم كله واستاذنكم ان الحل
الكيان شاء الله نتكلم على جانب اخر من
الصراع وتاثيره على العالم العربي ونربطه
برحله الامير محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد
الاخيره الى باكستان والهند اشكركم والى
لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]